but in parts of the US people are braced  for potentially record breaking low  temperatures as a so-called polar vortex  brings more freezing weather so what is  a polar vortex when it occurs at the  Earth's poles and it's an anti clockwise  rotating pool of frigid dense air but  with a calm Center now that air which is  stuck in one place it just gets colder  and denser when the winds encircling the  air breaks down it can break away from  the pole spreading those freezing  conditions further across the globe now  unusually this arctic air is actually  heading south across Canada and the  United States where temperatures could  feel as low as minus 51 degrees Celsius  that's about minus 60 degrees fahrenheit  in Minnesota while the current weather  storm has already dropped to up to two  feet of snow across the country  including in North Dakota Chicago and as  far south as Oklahoma as well